(musique solennelle)
- La reine quitte Buckingham
pour une dernière fois.
Dtre de Londres, une
procession deslulus solennelles.
Derrière la dépouille,
le nouveau monarque
et les autres mereres
de la famille royale.
Pour un instant, les différends
semblent laissés de côté.
Destination : le palais
de Westminster.
C'est là que, comme son père,
sa mère et Winston Churchill
avant elle, Élisabeth II sera
exposée en chapelle ardente pour
les quatre prochains jours.
(musique religieuse)
Le long du parcours, une foule
imposante au point que certains
spectaururs ont dû être
refoulés.
C'est donc sur leur écran
de téléphone que se sont
rabattus ces Londoniens.
De toute façon, ils ont des
heures devant eux en attendant
de pouvoir se recueillir devant
le cercueil royal.
"Ce sera un moment intime",
anticipe cette Canadienne
établie à Londres depuis
plusieurs années. Une fois
son recueillement terminé,
elle agira comme bénévole.
"Je vis ici, c'est mon devoir,
dit-elle. Car dans la capitale,
les besoins organisationnels
sont immenses."
Circulation, rappel des
instructions et suivi de santé
auprès de ceux que la longue
attente pourrait affecter.
Après 33 000 personnes qui ont
défilé devant la dépouille
à Édimbourg, les autorités
londoniennes s'attendent à
un afflux encore plus important.
Pour être pratiquement au devani
sur les rives de la Tamise. Mais
pour lui, attendre importe peu.
Il explique que la reine a
continué d'occuper son rôle,
alors qu'à 70 ou 80 ans, elle
aurait dû être à la retraite.ete
la distance qu'a su conservernep
Pour être l'un des p
à la remercier, il aura attendu
une journée et demie.
Il est presque 17 h,
heure locale, moment auquel
les Britanniques pourront
commencer à se recueillir
devant la dépouille de la reine.
On se trouve ici à environ
quatre kilomètres de Westminster
Hall, le lieu où se tient
cette chapelle ardente et
cette longue file d'attente
continue de s'allonger.
"Rien de cette ampleur n'avait
été vu dans ce pays", constate
ce londonien, pourtant habitué
des événements royaux.
Une fois 17 h arrivé, la foule
entreprend son mouvement.
Le rythme est encourageant.
Mais vu la distance à parcourir,
il faudra encore patienter avant
de passer quelques secondes
seulement pour tourner une page
d'histoire et dire au revoir
à celle qui a régné sur le pays
pendant sept décennies.
ICI Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, à Londres.